inflation surged to 6.8 in november okay
even more than expected to fastest rate
since 1982
federal reserve is expected to take a
very big step towards a rate hike it's
what they're talking about right now
this is a cnbc story
uh they're they're about to announce a
dramatic policy shift wednesday that
will clear the way and they did it first
interest hike rate next year markets are
anticipating the fed will speed up the
wind down of its bond buying program
changing the end to march in uh from
june that would free the central bank to
start raising interest rates from zero
and fed officials are expected to
release a new forecast showing two to
three interest rate hikes in 2022 and
another three to four in 2023 the big
wild card for markets is what the fed
says about its balance sheet which was
4.1 trillion dollars in january the 2022
before pandemic was swollen to 8.7
trillion dollars you just mentioned that
there was uh
one set of analytics has said that
expecting as many as seven mini hikes
during the year no no i said that i just
said goldman sachs goldman sachs
surveillance seven isn't that
interesting well listen yesterday was a
shock a shock for the markets and
fed officials are being so aggressive
because they they announced that the the
median probability is now three
rate hikes according to fed officials
according to the dot plot according to
the anonymous votes so a a preponderance
of the the the officials on the federal
reserve board are now anticipating three
rate hikes next year but as we see
fed hikes
seen starting with yield curve flattest
in a generation
it's a wonky thing to discuss but the
reason stocks are up is because stocks
are like they're not going to be able to
do it
because
we we've had the difference between the
two-year treasury yield and the 10-year
treasury yield which is by the way what
i spent all of 2019 talking about i
spent all one whole year talking about
the damn yield curve but we've had the
difference between the two year and the
10-year yield go from 161 1.6 percentage
points in april at the peak of the
stimulus stimulus checks 3.0 to where it
is today half of that 80 basis points so
it's been cut in half so it's a record
decline once that yield curve gets
really flat it tends to say we're going
into recession so the markets yesterday
were like
they can try and raise interest rates
all they want but they cannot raise
interest rates if the yield curve is
flat or even worse inverted because that
signals a recession so try me go for it
hurry up with the taper right now
they're on track because they've doubled
the size of their the reduction in
purchases
to from 15 to 30 billion dollars
starting in january so they're on track
to finish with the taper to stop growing
the balance sheet by march 15 at the
rate that they have announced officially
yesterday so in theory on the march 17th
meeting two meetings from now they could
launch the first interest rate hike but
let's go back to tax season and the
money that people are not getting back
in interest in in income tax refunds
and the child tax credit not being paid
january the 15th for the first time and
biden
seeming to pull it out of his
the february the first student loan
repayment let's talk about what the
first quarter of this economy is going
to look like and whether the fed's going
to be able to do a single interest rate
despite inflation which there's a word
for it it's called stagflation and it's
the worst of all possible situations
because your growth is slowing while
prices are still rising it's the hardest
to break and it is the hardest to break
and wait till people start getting their
energy bills over the winter
they're gonna get hammered it's cold
forget it game over
you know when it comes to the biden
administration is going to be praying
for covet strain number six to distract
the american people from the fact that
a multi-point assault on the economy is
happening how bad do you think it's
going to be how bad do you think that jp
morgan came out yesterday morning and
they said you know what our healthcare
conference is going virtual
so let's try and multiply that out right
when travel's coming back right when
right right when all the everything in
person conferences i mean i've got them
lined up that's one of the biggest of
the year about it that's in san
francisco i believe it is it is now
virtual
could you imagine if people had access
to these types of conversations a year
ago right before the election do you
think it would have changed people's
minds knowing where the economy was
going because a lot of people predicted
this this isn't
you know executive order the usda into
increasing the food stamp program at 32
percent this is i mean this is like
what's being done to the us taxpayer
quietly is is just criminal
and you just need more people to talk
about it and i'm telling you 61 seats a
61-seat swing come november is going to
look like a walk in the park well what's
going to happen
in the house the narrative's already
shifted you can tell and it's a story
later if we want to talk about it but
even how some of these liberal mayors
are talking about crime right now
they're actually admitting that it
exists and you know that's a preemptive
strike for the elections but when it
comes to inflation i think sure
everybody has this but it's true aha
moment right when you realize inflation
is real for me it hit me the other day i
was at the grocery store i bought two
apples i was going to buy two apples two
apples it was like four bucks four four
fifty i'm going for for two apples
what's what's in the apple
well jackson had hidden some marijuana
that's what i'm saying
no wonder you're in a good mood it makes
sense i bought them apples i don't know
about 12 more i bought
these apples i like them apples that
david is in fuego this morning but you
know i don't need those apples that bad
i don't need apples right that's a
ridiculous four or five pounds i didn't
buy this differently for two apples i
didn't buy the pound of bacon
and somebody told
you have a problem with bacon this guy's
got a problem with apples so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]